well they say kids never come by unless
they need something
dad i need your help i'll get my coat
30 years in the future we are fighting a
war
our enemy is not human and we are losing
we need you to fight
i will be back and i love you chickpea
seven days from now when you're sent
into that war
you won't be fighting for your country
you'll be fighting for the world
is it all right yeah going to war stop
talking
listen sorry i mean when i'm nervous at
talk i'm like
97 on the nervous scale
that should be fun
welcome to the future you and your unit
are now
in 2051.
they're everywhere we are food and they
are hungry
our enemy is smarter
faster and stronger than you can
possibly imagine
do you want to see something really
dangerous i feel like literally that's
all i've been doing since i got here but
okay
within the next few weeks the human
species won't disappear from the face of
the earth
nothing we do here matters
that's where you're wrong i don't
believe that one bit
together we can stop this war from ever
happening
this is my opportunity to give this
world a second chance second chances are
really hard to come by
i'm not gonna hide
i'm gonna fight it's not even loaded
yeah well yeah it's not loaded it's a
pressurized cabin why would i load it
in the cabin the bullet goes in thing
and everybody sucked out
[Music]
you